♪♪♪
>>> YOU KNOW, WHEN I HIT 50, MY
BODY WENT THROUGH A BIG CHANGE
AND NOT FOR THE BETTER.
SEVERE ERECTILE DYSFUNCTION
SHATTERED MY CONFIDENCE, SENT ME
INTO A DEPRESSION, AND ALMOST
RUINED MY MARRIAGE.
AND BELIEVE ME, I TRIED
EVERYTHING.
BUT THEN, A FRIEND TOLD ME ABOUT
XENTREX, SO I TRIED IT, AND IT
WORKED.
>> XENTREX IS THE STRONGEST
MALE-ENHANCEMENT DRUG ON THE
MARKET.
IT INCREASES BLOOD FLOW, BOOSTS
TESTOSTERONE, AND ENDS ERECTILE
DYSFUNCTION INSTANTLY.
>> SO I ASKED MY DOCTOR ABOUT
XENTREX, AND HE SAID, "XENTREX?
WHAT THE HELL IS XENTREX?"
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND I SAID, "XENTREX, IT'S THE
STRONGEST MALE-ENHANCEMENT DRUG
IN THE WORLD, AND IT WORKS."
AND HE SAID HE NEVER HEARD OF
IT.
SO, I PULLED UP THE WEBSITE AND
SHOWED IT TO HIM.
HE STARTED LAUGHING.
HE SAID, "ARE YOU INSANE, MAN?
YOU CAN'T PUT THAT IN YOUR BODY.
IT'LL KILL YOU.
YOUR HEART WILL STOP.
RHINO HORN?
AMMONIUM HYDROXIDE?
THAT'S IN METH, RIGHT?"
>> XENTREX IS MADE STRONG ENOUGH
TO WORK ON THE MOST EXTREME
CASES OF ERECTILE DYSFUNCTION,
AND FAST!
>> MY DOCTOR ASKED ME, "WHERE
DID YOU HEAR ABOUT THAT
[ BLEEP ]?"
I TOLD HIM, "A FRIEND."
AND HE SAID, "WELL, WHAT'S HIS
NAME?"
AND I SAID, "WELL, I DON'T
REALLY KNOW HIM, ACTUALLY."
HE SAYS, BUT YOU JUST SAID HE'S
YOUR FRIEND.
SO, I TOLD MY DOCTOR, "LOOK,
LET'S FORGET ABOUT HIM, AND JUST
WRITE ME A SCRIP FOR XENTREX,
AND I'LL BE ON MY WAY."
MY DOCTOR SAID, "ARE YOU DEAF,
MAN?"
"NO."
"I COULD LOSE MY LICENSE.
YOU COULD DIE."
I SAID, "YEAH, I STILL WANT IT,
THOUGH.
SO GIVE IT TO ME.
WRITE THE PRESCRIPTION."
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
I WASN'T LEAVING.
SO, HE SAYS, "I THINK THAT
WEBSITE JUST FROZE MY COMPUTER."
SO I GRABBED HIM A LITTLE.
HE GOES, "YOU'RE HURTING ME,
SIR."
XENTREX WORKS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SIDE EFFECTS OF XENTREX
INCLUDE FITS OF RAGE, ACNE,
BLEEDING, BALDNESS, BLINDNESS,
WHOOPING COUGH, HALLUCINATIONS,
COMA, TROUBLE SWALLOWING,
DECREASE IN SEMEN, INCREASE IN
SEMEN, NASAL SORES,
CONSTIPATION, VOMITING, NIGHT
TERRORS, AMNESIA, AND SUICIDAL
URGES.
>> THOSE ARE JUST THE SYMPTOMS
THEY TELL YOU ABOUT.
I GET SWEATS.
MY BONES ARE COLD.
MY TEETH ARE LOOSE.
MY HEART GETS REALLY, REALLY
HOT.
I COULD READ MINDS, AND
SOMETIMES, I WAKE UP DRIVING A
STOLEN CAR.
MY ERECTIONS ARE FANTASTIC.
WHEN I WEAR GRAY SWEAT PANTS,
PEOPLE CROSS THE STREET.
WHICH IS FINE.
XENTREK GAVE ME MY LIFE BACK.
HAIL SATAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SO, THREATEN YOUR DOCTOR, OR
ASK YOUR KETAMINE GUY ABOUT
SOUTH AFRICAN XENTREK TODAY.
>> A, HA, HA, HA, HA, HA!
IT WORKS!
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]